your perspective on where we are today
well first of course I know everybody is
thinking of the families of the two
officers went down in the young woman
who was that was killed in this event
and it started with these white
supremacists who decided to come to
Charlottesville to protest the taking
down of a statue of Robert Ely and we
have to remember that what that statue
is about is slavery that's what the
Confederacy was about the cornerstone
speech that was given by the vice
president of the Confederacy a few days
for the Civil War started said the
cornerstone of this of the Confederacy
is slavery mm-hmm and that the Negro he
said was in is inferior and should be
enslaved and that and that's the real
history of this and these were white
supremacist coming to protest that
taking down the statue which I guess the
town of Charlottesville voted to do and
they knew this had been decided a while
ago they knew was gonna be taken down so
they prepared for this event
yeah and they did and they came wearing
helmets and bringing clubs and and and
then and the violence started and there
were protesters there to protest there
they're coming there and this driver
who's been charged injured 20 people and
killed this lovely young woman and very
unbelievably sad and president Trump
instead of condemning the white
supremacist just went out and said I
condemn all violence from everybody
well sighs all sides yeah and I I
thought that was horrible and it was
very him and just
finally I guess today he said something
that maybe it would have been fine if he
had said two days ago about these white
supremacist we can't allow these people
to be there essentially being brown
shirts they were neo-nazis and
unfortunately I don't know why on that
first day he did not condemn what they
did and I fear that he thinks this is
part of his base or something but I I
don't anyway just it was a tragic day
and and we hope that that doesn't happen
again yeah there's a there's a seems to
me well first of all he got blowback and
criticism from his own party prominent
members of the party said this is not a
liberal or conservative left or right
Democrat a Republican disagreement
people you mana Messiah
I know that's a big thing for you is
getting both sides of the aisle to try
and agree on snow and I was very pleased
that a number of my Republican
colleagues did that and it was pretty
wide spread you know condemnation I of
his just of his I I can't explain why he
said that other than him thinking that
this is part of his basic right well
what's you know apparent to me is as you
know there's a lot a president can do
constitutional but there's a lot a
president can't do there's a lot that a
president can enact there's a lot of
ways that the president can't make
things happen but I think in the modern
era more than ever one of the biggest
things that a president can do is at a
time like this be eloquent and bring
everybody together it's and and we've
had Republican and Democratic presidents
that have done that beautifully there's
been a crisis and they've brought
everybody together with eloquent words
and it feels like this is almost a
softball like this is a very easy thing
to come out
yeah well the day that it happened to be
flowery
it can just be simply stated that we
just condemn all hatred mm-hmm and
that's not us that's not America this
isn't who we are it you know I'm you
know W George W Bush after 9/11 made
sure that he said that Muslims aren't
right who were you know that we we don't
have a problem with Islam right and so
this this this I have trouble with this
breath right yeah
you